well firstly I was struck by I think
well I think in terms of animation I
think it's one of the most human forms
still available to us that you can
always feel the human hand behind it it
doesn't really matter what the format is
I would love just if you could all
please just we could go down the line
and introduce ourselves and just just a
little bit about the decision to to
embrace the certain type of animation
because we've had you know something
from do basketball which was incredibly
energetic and raw and has a very human
you know feel behind it and you know
something to the very next film
garden-party were just photo real and so
you so much information so much detail
today and I think it's just for me it's
fascinating just to find out what you
know where that decision came from Kobe
Bryant I used to play basketball I think
for us the the reason why we wanted to
do animation and also do hand-drawn
animation is because the the the core of
the story carries such a rawness to it
and you're building a career there's a
lot of imperfections that come along
with that and we wanted to find the
beauty and the imperfection of those
lines which you know go in if you only
get an animator to do it and run it's
got to be doing so
[Applause]
glen keane
thank you for me it's all about living
in the skin of the character that you're
animating and I mean I've been a mermaid
and a beast but I never thought I could
be Kobe Bryant you know that's like and
drawing to me is is really something
that's very deeply expressive I mean I
think of line as like a seismograph of
your soul as you're drawing it it's
putting something real that you're
feeling and I mean I I felt like I I did
all the things that you did out there
you know it's just it was really cool
thank you
I'm Victor and this is Gabriel we used
to be students and we we wanted to find
a job and we liked animals and that's
pretty much it so
thank you
Dave Mullins yeah for me I since I was a
kid I was into computers and animation
and drawing in films and you know
animations just where I've always loved
being and animating and for me the story
is basically taking everything that I've
learned from being an animator designing
writing directing everything and just
putting into a film that was really
personal for me
so yeah the especially computer
animation there's just something I fell
in love with like when I was a kid I saw
Tron and my brain kind of melted when I
saw that and ever really seen that
before
and I've just been chasing it ever since
and the medium to me is just I think
it's it's limitless and you see it's you
know just animation in general you see
everything all the filmmakers up here
and all the amazing work that was done
and it's represented across so many
different types of the medium so yeah I
think animation to me is just I'll
always be attracted to it the producer
blue and yeah I think what's so
incredible about all of the stories that
are told they could only be told in
animation
unless we've filmed you Kobe but they're
just all so beautiful and it's
incredible and so just to be up here
with all of you is an honor
[Applause]
hello my name is Rikuo I co-directed
negative space with max Porter
so the film is based on 150 word poem by
Ron curtsy who's in the audience today
[Applause]
and these stories about relationship
between father and son but it's about
packing so we thought that we needed to
make the objects and clothes alive and
we thought the stop-motion was the best
way animation is the best way to portray
this story yeah and the only thing I
would want to add is with stop-motion
because you are touching objects and the
touch the textures are rich and alive on
the screen we thought that it would help
the audience connect with what was going
on inside the film hello I'm Jana hawa
and co-directed this with Jacobson there
so we grew up in Bavaria and we grew up
on Roald Dahl with German German
translations of Roald Dahl so we didn't
know this collection of poems that our
film is based on does this work and so
we we were made aware of it sort of many
years after we'd read all of dolls work
and it just that book separate poems and
it just it was writing written in 1981
and it just seemed incredibly modern and
fitting and we could imagine this to be
a great film and so we went added thank
you I'm not reading these aren't
questions these aren't anything prepared
I'm just looking at this other thing
okay so when you Koby when you wrote the
that piece for the players Tribune did
you ever have any idea at the time that
you wanted to turn it into something
else or ideal I got you know I wanted to
you know visual learner so I wanted to
write a film that was going to help the
next generation learn and you know I'm
not big on picking up things from a
reading standpoint and absorbing them I
got to read it like five times and so I
was thinking the next generation it's
probably similar to that so I figure out
make a film
this way they can kind of sit with it
learn by seeing and absorb the message
so I had an idea I wanted to do it swing
for the fences and win for Glenn and win
for John which still sounds freaking
ridiculous oh yes you know you can't hit
the ball if you don't swing the damn bat
right so and so yeah I had a general
idea and and how is if you just getting
the call and then and you know not much
of a decision it's just a normal thing
Kobe you know I was geeking out cuz I
was like I was telling where area on the
beasts what the hell is going on
it was pretty wonderful Kobe came over
to our tiny we have a tiny little studio
in West Hollywood and I I thought in
when Kobe came in it's like he's not
gonna be impressed with this place at
all and and he came in and he stood
there and he just kind of looked around
said just perfect
so first had to duck through the frame
yeah they said why he said well it's
just real it just it was it was just a
tiny little place with a lot of drawings
on the wall and and right from the very
beginning he wanted it to be hand-drawn
handcrafted just like the game of
basketball
yeah that's what we did working with Max
keen our production designer and Jenny
Ram our producer he said he said I had
the worst and person that can animate
basketball in the history he said I
won't understand anything about
basketball is what he said to me so
that's fantastic is a lot of draw for
[ __ ] so it's par for the course and then
then giant comes in a pitch and goes you
know I got to be honest I've never been
to a basketball game what the hell
now one no not high school when that
college never been to one I said John
you were in LA when Showtime magic cat
you know I mean it was like who's going
on he drops the michaelmi with George
and Steven kept me busy that's it and
then and then you go so where did this
thing come from
how translate for myself where did it
come from
very kind then you come from it's a
student project very c6 quadratic 12
there is photo in the room yeah I stand
up there yeah the future was
brainstorming all together and we knew
that we wanted to do something with
animals we knew that we wanted to add
something a little bit more matures so
we are the crime scene little bit of
Paula and voila it's very easy folks
it's very easy no study of frogs just
made that up
no you have that the problem is frog the
active frogs was amateurs so it was
sometimes really hard to other all
amateurs
made it okay you guys I mean for me the
you know the film it came from when I
was a kid I moved around a lot and you
know like twice a year it'd be like the
new kid at school and so you know if
anybody's been a new kid at school you
know how like awkward you feel and off
and weird and you know if you'd gone to
a new job or whatever and so you know I
was thinking about that a lot when I was
coming up with you know three ideas to
pitch and just the idea of a character
that could kind of hide in plain sight
at Pixar and it picks around if you've
seen Pixar films before but we like to
bring never in animate the company code
the thing that we do like let's take
that and give it a job but you know I
was thinking about that and really the
idea came out of that experience and I
really wanted to kind of find a foil for
that character that was you know you
look at a lost-and-found box it's a cool
thing for my animation point of view
you're like oh my god how are we going
to make a character out of baseballs and
and junk and crap the juicer leaving
around the school and so you know you
get this character and you discover you
know that you know Lawson found blocks
it's mink to give things back to the
original owners and so any story good
story needs conflicts so the best
conflict for that's a bully and when you
get that character in there and we found
that that's when I think that the heart
of it came together and you know my kids
and both of our kids were dealt with
bullying at school and we've had to talk
to her kids a lot about that and so it
all just rang true for us and it was
exciting and it's really challenging is
a really crazy character to make every
shot a different characters and we have
some of our crew that showed up as well
they animated those crazy shots which
was incredible Garcia and then you guys
one of the most time-consuming of all
stars of animation there is the you know
I'm more interesting like the came from
but also the timeline of how long the
entire thing took just from construction
of everybody else props and everything
and in the characters so the development
took about a year while we were looking
for funding and then the production is
selfless nine months total divided into
three months of set puppet and prop
making three months of shooting and
three months of post-production but we
had a really amazing support from France
we moved and lived there for nine months
period and we got a lot of support from
eki films in my new home studio both
artistically and financially so I just
want to introduce my crew
and early data we're Sylvanas here as
well they'll still gonna keep talking
where they looked at my name is all the
mess anyway doesn't matter how it was
animation hood yeah we all know it as
[Music]
what you're part of it and I'm not gonna
ask you what it was like writing it but
incredible I mean like yeah I grew up
with those stories I'm sure like many
people here did as well absolutely
incredible animation and yeah how why
when how long I want the sort of I want
the half an hour commentary on the in
traffic in one minute so everything
started with our producers approaching
us with that book and we both read it
and immediately fell in love with it we
both know Rohit I quite well we both
from Germany but we didn't know that
specific book but as we read it we liked
it a lot and yeah we started thinking
about how could we adapt it started
looking at the poems and at the
characters what are their motifs and we
immediately had a feeling at because
several like they are separate poems
that's six separate points in the book
and we chose three of them to make this
film because we had the feeling they all
belong to one world
and yeah we started with the story and
then it's a our third director came on
board it's been done too you know and so
I was very over there yeah I heard that
enough II heard that was it how when and
why I want yep 16 months the tricky bit
was literally that there were
unconnected poems everything that you
saw that were relationships between
these between these characters like Snow
White and little bit Riding Hood isn't
in the book they're separate stories so
by connecting them all but not adding
any new rhymes all of these
relationships had to be worthless
without hopefully you feeling that
they're worthless so writing took a long
time to go out for months to write it
and then we had to really hurry up to
make it because it we wanted to coincide
with a hundredth birthday so there was a
really solid deadline to that and yeah
it was good fun but not not a lot of
sleep is this birthday this year
what's that his 100th birthday this year
I know his last year house you have to
do that happy hundred month once what
okay well guess what s into that no
questions from the audience
what is the Academy they're just very
strict I'll take one okay one question
this is very unconventional they told me
not to but I'm a rule-breaker just like
him just me and him
rule breakers okay yeah oh yeah surprise
for us
what's the question
[Laughter]
you saying it's not fair oh oh dude I'm
sitting up here with Pixar you asked me
that question
Pixar yeah no um I'm tripping out about
this whole thing cuz you know like going
to the Oscar luncheon was nuts cuz I'm
sitting there and I'm looking at all of
these phenomenal actors and actresses
and writers and music composer composers
and I'm just wondering what the hell am
I doing here
it may sound like yesterday I was
playing basketball and I met the Academy
luncheon so it's completely freaking me
out to be here like even though just to
be here right now is really bizarre to
me but it's pretty awesome dude so I
don't know I'm just hanging out look on
that note we've got a little
intermission
I just love to congratulate all of you
again on your nominations it's an
incredible feat congratulations better
bloke
[Applause]